in this country the defamation trial
exposing the very complicated
relationship between amber heard and
johnny depp reached the critical phase
in virginia yesterday depp is suing herd
for 50 million dollars accusing her of
ruining ruining his acting career after
she wrote an op-ed article about
domestic abuse hurd is counter-suing
debt for 100 million dollars nikki
batiste has the latest
because he's guilty
because he's he knows he's lying
otherwise why can't he look at me in her
final day on the stand actress amber
hurd was grilled about the abuse she
says she took from ex-husband johnny
depp this is a man who tried
to kill me the 36 year old claims that
during an alcohol fueled rage in
australia depp assaulted her both
physically and sexually but depp
contended that he was the victim and
that he lost the tip of his middle
finger when heard threw a vodka bottle
at him you're the one who assaulted
someone with a bottle in australia isn't
that right misheard i didn't assault
johnny in australia i didn't assault
johnny ever depp's attorney questioned
herd about several journal entries and
love notes she wrote for depp in the
months following the alleged assault
since we fought so much it was important
for me to
[Music]
you know try to nurture as much peace as
we possibly could depp's lawyers also
accused heard of editing this photo of
herself allegedly showing bruises on her
face isn't it true you just edited these
photographs no i've never edited a
photograph depp has denied ever hitting
his wife when questioned about her
december 2018 op-ed in the washington
post the actress denied that the essay
was about depp
it's not about mr death it is not about
him mr death is making it about mr duff
right
ironically
cbs news legal analyst ricky clemen
a jury could simply say
this relationship was a house of horrors
and a pox on both their houses and so
we're not going to award either of them
any money and that is indeed a distinct
possibility for cbs mornings i'm nikki
batiste